ALEX LEVICH: Hi everyone,
this is Alex Levich.
I'm a product manager at Google.
Today we'll be talking
about product management.
And we have a great
guest with us,
Aparna, who is actually
building Google Now,
the smart assistant
of the future.
Aparna's going to
share some insights
about the different skills
that product managers need.
Welcome, Aparna.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Thank you.
Happy to be here.
ALEX LEVICH: Wonderful.
Aparna, tell us, in your career,
what kind of skills did you see
is important for product
managers to have?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
I think I mean,
if I were to draw the feature
spec for a PM, if you will,
I think the baseline
characteristic that I look for,
and I think that's a huge
predictor of your success,
is growth mindset.
Right?
That is, are you able to think
of an experience, a failure,
and actually say, what are
the things that you can learn
from it, and what are the
specific learnings that you can
apply in the next
phase of your career
or next phase of your
project, and so on.
And that sounds
super cliche, right?
Everyone's talking about this
growth mindset and like--
ALEX LEVICH: So important
for in our industry.
Changes every day.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Exactly,
I mean it's super cliche
to say this, but in the tech
industry, the way you succeed
is by failing.
Take every successful
product worth its salt,
both within Google, but also
apps like Twitter or Instagram
or the recent one, Slack,
where literally, it
grew out of a failed
gaming startup, right?
And it's unclear
that you can actually
get to good instincts
and good judgment
without actually burning
your hands and experiencing--
ALEX LEVICH: It's all
feelings and learning, yeah.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
So to me, I
think that's a huge
characteristic.
If you're unable or unwilling
to learn from failure,
that's a difficult transition
to make into PM because that's
exactly how you learn.
I do think the
typical skills that
are useful for a successful
product manager--
and these three
things are things
that I keep thinking
about, which
is one is, I mean the
name is product manager,
so you do need to
have product judgment.
And again, that's not something
that you're born with or not.
It's something that's honed
and developed repeatedly.
But the instinct about
what makes-- you're
in the business of
making useful products.
ALEX LEVICH: Useful
products, yeah.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
You need to have
a good judgment and a nose
for what's useful versus not.
That's table stakes.
I think the second thing I think
about is more around execution,
and specifically, OK, it's great
you have a great product plan.
But you're here.
How do you actually
build that onramp?
How do you break down things
into manageable stuff?
ALEX LEVICH: How do you
translate vision into reality?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Right?
Into reality.
And to me, a lot of product
managers kind of struggle
there because they're
either really good
at painting this
20,000 feet picture
or really good at the
day-to-day minutiae.
ALEX LEVICH: You
mentioned failure
as part of growth mindset.
That's very interesting.
Tell us about a failure of
yours where you learned a lot.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
So in my own case,
I think one of the
examples that comes to mind
is-- when I first joined Google,
I was working on these projects
with-- so I was the PM
for this research team
that was doing amazing
things with computer vision.
And one of the product ideas I'd
come up with is, wait a minute,
we have YouTube.
Can we apply this
computer vision technology
to detect objects within videos?
Wouldn't it be cool
if you could say--
ALEX LEVICH: I think it's cool.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
--hey, this
is a racing car,
a race car video.
Or this is a video with a
helicopter or whatever, right?
ALEX LEVICH: That's what people
are still trying to do today.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: They're
still trying to do it,
and now, the thing
that was-- well,
it was a failure, first of all.
It didn't go anywhere.
But the reason it was a
failure, or in retrospect,
what I learned was that
it was a bit too early.
That is, the stage of
YouTube as a product
there was-- the product
was just getting traction.
There's some basic
first startup problems
that the team was
trying to solve.
Basically, being able to say,
I don't know, Justin Bieber,
and find videos.
ALEX LEVICH: Yeah, yeah.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: Or
being able to monetize a site,
being able to scale
the bandwidth issues.
And so here I was, I had
this futuristic idea.
And it was just too early.
So that's one
lesson I've learned.
That's one kind of failure
where there's a timing issue.
You can do everything right.
ALEX LEVICH: That makes sense.
Yeah.
You got to-- [INAUDIBLE].
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
So that's one mistake
that I won't make again.
There'll be others.
ALEX LEVICH: Tell us
about you personally.
Across your career,
what are the skills
that made you personally be
great, be very successful
product leader?
Whether it's at Google Now or
before, what comes to mind?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
I think one
of the things I've been able
to do again by just learning
and improving is this onramp
that I talk about between
there's a huge,
very powerful idea,
and there is basically
us at the start--
ALEX LEVICH: At the beginning.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
--at the beginning.
And how do you actually
build this onramp from here
to there, but in a way that's
sustainable and tractable.
Right?
ALEX LEVICH: And brings
user value along the way.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: And brings
user value across the way.
And I think it's one
of those things where
if you do it too-- if you
build a very steep onramp,
you may get far enough soon,
but very soon you'll burn out.
You kind of slip back.
And if it's too
slow, then you just
don't get enough
momentum, right?
So that's one thing at least.
So for a--
ALEX LEVICH: It's
a tough balance.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
It's a tough balance.
ALEX LEVICH: Very important.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Right, and I
think it's the trade off between
how do you actually build
the right set of
initial features
that still makes the
product successful
and engaging, but then
not say that, oh yeah,
we'll throw the kitchen
sink into the first version.
Which is a temptation
for all product managers.
ALEX LEVICH: Yes.
I was kind of watching
you guys build Google Now.
You have this amazing
vision, this assistant
of the future that knows
everything and helps
with everything, right?
And we are kind of
in the beginning.
And we see more and
more and more and more.
So that's fascinating to see.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Yeah, and it's
very tempting because
you say, OK, you're
frustrated that, oh,
the product should
be able to do everything
and then some.
But the reality is that
you have to pace yourself.
You have to steadily
increase the user value here.
ALEX LEVICH: What are you most
excited about from Google Now?
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: I'm
just motivated by the fact
that these phones
have kind of turned
3.5 billion users into
broadcasting machines, right?
It's a whole bunch
of information
being generated all the while
by so many folks talking.
And now suddenly-- but in a
world where everyone talking,
you just need to have the
selective listening, right?
You--
ALEX LEVICH: Absolutely.
There's way too much
information, information
overload.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA: There's
way too much information.
Yeah.
And you have to be able to pay
attention to the information
that you need, and
that you can act on
that makes your life,
the day-to-day hundreds
and hundreds of
micro-decisions that you
make throughout the day better.
And I feel like
we have a chance,
we have a crack at
solving that problem.
ALEX LEVICH: It's not
about adding information.
It's about reducing
information--
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
It's about filtering it
down to what you want.
Yeah.
ALEX LEVICH: Yeah,
that's awesome.
That's awesome.
Aparna, thanks for
sharing your insights.
It's been great and, I'm sure,
very valuable to our viewers.
APARNA CHENNAPRAGADA:
Yeah, thank you.
ALEX LEVICH: Thanks,
everyone, for watching.
Subscribe to Women
Techmakers YouTube channel
and stay tuned for
upcoming episodes
about product management.
Thanks.